most important reason for whatever  success i've had has been meditation  i learned it you know when the beatles  did it over in india and they came back  and i heard about it and i went to the  center that had you know you bring some  a flower and you bring some that tough  and they taught me meditation and what  meditation has given me is equanimity  and creativity you go into yourself into  that state of transcendence and when  you're there  you're connected with your subconscious  and from your subconscious comes uh this  creativity and it comes this equanimity  and so that has been healthy and it's  been also helping my thinking so because  in your life just so many things come at  you and to be able to have that peace  and like a ninja to be able to think how  do i execute  it's a real blessing